اذا ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو الصحفي
والناقد الفنيه اسامه الفا اسامه صباح
الخير صباح النور صباح النور صباح النور
راويه
اليوم هاري ضحيه ام طالب تسويه ماليه اكيد
مش ضحيه
اكيد مش ضحيه لانه يعني هو شخصيه اول شيء
شخصيه ملكيه شخصيه اعتباريه هلا نحن أنا
هون لهاجمه اكيد ولا لدافع عن الصحافه بس
بالنهايه الصحافه سواء كانت شعبيه هي
التابلت والصحافه الصفراء
بريطانيا او صحافه تقليديه الكبيره شغل
انه توصل الخبر كيف بتوصل لهيدا الخبر هو
كان لازم يحمي نفسه يعني ما معقوله امير
وابن عائله حاكمه ومالكه وما يكون قادر
يعني ينتبه على موضوع فردان الاختراق
الهاتف اللي كان عم يتعرض له او اختراق
البريد الصوتي مثل ما قال
اخترق اخترقوا البريد الصوتي مره مرتين
ثلاثه بالسته سنين سبع سنين عشر سنين ما
معقوله يعني
احنا عم نحكي عن عم نحكي من 96 لل كان طفل
فعليا 96 لما ولا 97 لما توفت
كان طفله بس احنا
اساليب غير قان
ونيه معلومات الصحافه تعتبرها انه هي من
حقها تحصل عليها
خصوصيه وفي شخصيه اعتباريه طب ما هو مش هو
شخص يمكن المسؤول عن حمايه نفسه من
الاختراقات الهاتفيه ولكن المنظومه
يعني يعني كان المفروض انه حمايه هاري متل
ما مثلا ابوه كان محمي اكثر يعني اللي صار
هلا
ما كان في
بس كان ايضا ابو عرضه
لتطفل الصحافه صح اكيد اكيد طبعا بس يعني
قدروا يحموه وهو قدر يجابه الصحافه بطريقه
مختلفه قبل ما يكون ملك يعني نحن عم نحكي
ايام ما كان حتى ولي عهد قدر يواجه هذا
الموضوع بالنهايه عمل اللي هو بده اياه
سواء بحياته الشخصيه انا اسف بس الصحافه
البريطانيه ايضا قاسيه على الملكه على ولي
العهد على يعني دائما ما ترى انه الصحافه
البريطانيه تبحث عن عن هذه الاخبار التي
من الممكن ان تثير نحن نحكي عن الصحافه
الشعبيه الصحافه الشعبيه هذا قوته يعني
بالنهايه
لحتى تدفعهن يعني بالنهايه هذا شغلهم
خلينا نحكي شغله الصحافه الصفراء اذا دفعت
هذه الملايين مئه مليون جنيه استرليني
بتكون عامله 500 مليون من ورا هاي الاخبار
طبعا ناويه انا ما عم دافع عن الصحافه
الصفراء اكيد
[ضحك]
انا برايي يعني انا كصحفي
انا اليوم لما انا بصلح خبر وبدي انشره
فهذا حقي باي طريقه انا وصلت له اكيد انا
ما عم بشجع الطرق الملتويه بس بالنهايه
الاخبار احيانا ممكن توصلك
بس في عرف اسامه في في نحن عنا
اخلاق
عنا قانون عنا شيء مختلف عنه نحن نقارن
مثلا ما بين الدول العربيه العالم العربي
وبريطانيا عندهم قانون مختلف عندهم ما في
مثلا
حدود لا دنيا ولا عليا للاخلاق يعني اصلا
بمجتمع مختلف تماما على المجتمعاتنا وهذا
الشيء مش بس بريطانيا على فكره يعني حتى
بتركيا اللي هي دوله اسلاميه بتلاقي مثلا
الباباراتزي شغالين وما حدا بيقدر يوقفهم
وانا شخصيا شفت هذا الشيء بعيني يعني
وانصدمت انه
بروسيه باكثر من دوله بالعالم
يعني اصلا الاميره ديانا راحت ضحيه هيدا
الموضوع لا ما انا ما ابي اوصل لهالدرجه
شكرا جزيلا الصحفيه والنقد الفني اسامه
شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات